good afternoon everyone
i'm dr miller and the scp we're going to
be looking at today
is scp-4054
object class safe
special containment procedures three nes
nintendo entertainment system consoles
modified
to run scp-4054 are to be kept for
testing purposes
scp-4054 is to be stored on site
in a secure locker access is limited to
level 3 personnel
and above foundation agents monitoring
flea markets
yard sales and property auctions for
anomalous activity
are to be briefed on the existence of
scp-4054
any nes cartridges suspected of being
copies of scp-4054
are to be purchased for examination a
foundation-operated bot
io sauron is to monitor online gaming
communities for discussions regarding
the existence of scp-4054
a joint operation involving mobile task
force meu4
debuggers and mobile task force gamma 5
red herrings is to be conducted to
investigate these discussions and
determine whether their participants are
aware of scp-4054
all copies are to be recovered and
action is to be taken to discredit the
existence
of scp-4054 as a hoax or urban legend
any screen captures or videos of
scp-4054
are to be removed or otherwise replaced
with doctored images to further
perpetuate this narrative
description scp-4050
is the seventh door an unlicensed
platform adventure game released for the
nintendo entertainment system
in 1988. the contents of each cartridge
vastly exceeds the storage limitations
of its rom chip
read-only memory extracting scp-4054's
prg rom
produces a data file too large to be
contained on any currently available
device
because of its limited publication 300
units
ability to be copied limited
replayability
and incomplete state functional copies
of the seventh door
are highly valued by vintage nes
collectors
the game is also notable for its unique
method of bypassing the north american
version of the 10nes
lockout system the 10nes lockout system
was designed by nintendo to prevent
unlicensed cartridges from operating on
their consoles
each cartridge includes two transistors
that function as a voltage inverter
when activated this component produces a
negative charged voltage spike that can
temporarily disable early versions
of the console's cic checking integrated
circuit
bypassing the authentication lock and
allowing unlicensed cartridges to run
later iterations of the nes would add a
series of 1k resistors
along with diodes and grounds to prevent
this technique from circumventing the
lockout unit
however a defect in this voltage
inverter's design
causes irreparable damage to the seventh
door's sram
static random access memory with each
successive reset
this produces an increasing number of
glitches which will inevitably render
the cartridge
non-functional the seventh door was
shipped
prior to completion as a consequence
several core components of gameplay
differ from what is depicted in its
instruction manual
and box art the protagonist has no extra
lives
upon dying all progress is lost the
cartridge resets
all power-ups described in the manual
are absent save one
the hand of glory according to european
folklore a hand of glory is the left
hand of a man who has been
hanged for murder when used as a candle
those who perceive its light cannot
approach its holder
which prevents monsters and platforms
from moving for 10 seconds
all monsters are absent falling into a
pit
does not kill the protagonist the
protagonist will instead continue to
fall off screen
as the game over sound loops memory
overflow errors periodically cause
sprites to load incorrectly
the prisoners use the protagonist's
sprite rather than their own
after unlocking a door prisoners provide
no clue regarding the location of other
keys
the text boxes are empty the protagonist
dies at apparently random intervals
typically after a period of remaining
still this occurs regardless of whether
or not the game is paused
to date researchers have uncovered
several hundred levels beyond the
seventh
described in the manual as the final
level and the location of the seventh
key
these stages consist of vast networks of
crypts
prisons abandoned factories and empty
underground cities
the precise number of additional levels
beyond the seventh has not yet been
determined but
vastly exceeds the storage capacity of
the cartridge's rom chip
the seventh level does not contain the
7th key
addendum 4054 1
video stream in 2004
charles rogers an amateur nes cartridge
collector
posted a thread at
www.openingthe7thdoor.int
a defunct online forum that was
dedicated to the 7th door
under the username inky49 there he
suggested using an nes
game genie produced in 1990 the game
genie is a game enhancing module that
attaches between the nes cartridge
and console it permits direct
modification of reference addresses in
the realm of the cartridge
via strings of characters or code to
directly set the value associated with
the protagonist's number of keys
to seven several days later
mr rogers posted a link to an online
video stream where he intended to
attempt to beat the seventh door
using this exploit partway through his
run the video
abruptly stopped a follow-up
investigation determined that mr rogers
had gone missing
authorities suspected foul play after
discovering
several fingernails torn from mr rogers
left hand
inside his nes console no copy of the
seventh door was recovered
to date scp-4054 has been linked to
25 disappearances it remains under
investigation
well what can you really say about this
one
i'm sorry fellow gamers this one it's
probably best to stay away from
anyway thank you all for listening if
indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
suser hintern zarguran
onyx arbiter seoul
the morrigan retalias
karim el ashmoey the alpha walrus
patrick bailey dreams
matthew gilmore eric corbish
kauai fire keeper joker corvus
king madding james saba
and nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vorgen thank you
you